JENNY BROWN: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a series where
we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around
because in this episode,
you'll learn about
Cloud audit logging.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE DIALING]
BRAD ACTOR: Salutations,
Cloud detective.
Last episode, you
used service accounts
to foil my grand attempt
to compromise your apps
and scripts that allow
for automated access
into your system.
This time, I decided
to go old school.
One of your employees is logging
in in the middle of the night
and accessing things
they shouldn't be.
How do I know this?
Well, maybe it's because
you're not their only employer.
The question is, in a
fully remote workplace,
how are you ever
going to track down
who the wayward employee is?
If you don't do
something soon, I just
might have to ask
our mutual employee
to make some unfortunate
changes to a slideshow.
How embarrassing would it
be if all of your images
were replaced with cats at the
next company-wide presentation?
JENNY BROWN: All right,
so here's what we know.
Admins are responsible for
coming up with solutions
to the many ways users can
interact with their systems.
And in this case, we
need to track down
who's accessing files
when they shouldn't be.
If this was at the
office, we could
ask the security
guards to walk around
and note if they see
anything suspicious.
And if we were at the
office, we would actually
be able to look at
the security logs
to see whose keycard
was being used to access
the building late at night.
Wait a minute.
That gives me an idea.
See, Google Cloud provides
a lot of tools and services
to protect its users from
cases just like this.
And one of the most
important tools
is called Google
Cloud Audit Logs,
which lets teams easily
create and manage audit logs.
Regardless of how carefully
we code or thoroughly
debug a piece of software,
problems are going to come up.
And when they do,
it's almost impossible
to determine why they happened
and figure out how to fix them
unless there's a
trail of breadcrumbs
to follow along the way.
And security logging provides
that crucial trail of evidence.
So during an active
investigation or postmortem
analysis, having regular
logs to go through
is critical to identify
the cause of the issue.
They help establish baselines
and find operational trends.
Logging security
events that keep
track of every
activity that happens
in the digital environment,
your organization
will monitor these logs
for any suspicious activity
or unauthorized
access to the system.
Whenever these
breaches are found,
the data is moved to
a central database
so that the security team
can then investigate them.
Hmm, I need to
investigate this more.
When it comes to Google's
Cloud Audit Logs,
some types of logs, like
Admin Activity logs,
are on by default and
can't be disabled.
Others, like Data Access
logs, are optional,
off by default, and
cost money to use.
Logs that are not essential
are turned off by default
to save users money because
the logs could take up
a large amount of data that
would apply against Google's
quotas and limits.
But depending on what you
need, Cloud Audit Logs
provide many customization
options to suit an organization
and fulfill all their
security logging needs.
So these include the
aforementioned Admin Activity
audit logs, which
cover API calls
and admin actions that modify
how metadata for resources
is configured.
Whenever VM
instances are created
or identities are changed,
a log record is kept.
These logs are
automatically kept,
don't cost users anything,
and can't be disabled.
Then there's Data Access audit
logs, which keep track of users
as they create, change, and read
data that's been user provided.
These do have costs
associated with them,
except for BigQuery's
Data Access audit logs.
And Data Access audit
logs aren't on by default
because they can
store a lot of data.
And then there's
System Event audit
logs to track changes to how
resources are configured.
These logs are triggered
by Google systems,
don't cost anything,
and can't be disabled.
And finally, there's
Policy Denied audit logs.
Those are created whenever a
Google Cloud service denies
access to a user or service
account because of a security
policy violation.
These are on by
default but do have
costs associated with them.
So we've got a lot of log
information to sort through,
but it's important to
understand that audit logs have
no concept of suspicious events
and are often best-effort items
that can be delayed
by up to five minutes.
And still, once
your security team
is aware of a suspicious
event, your team
will need to have the
correct tools and data
to work with to
assess the situation
and take action as appropriate.
And luckily in our case, we
turned on Data Access logs.
So let's look at those and
see who's been calling what
and when.
And by taking a look at who's
been accessing files they
shouldn't have, eureka, I was
able to figure out who's been
accessing files they shouldn't.
BRAD ACTOR: Drats, you
figured that out so quickly,
although it does make me wonder
why a regular scan of activity
wasn't already part
of your process.
Google Cloud has
tools that allow
you to set up real-time
alerts and notifications.
And regardless of if
you use those or not,
your company should
implement an audit process
that involves regularly
reviewing the logs
for suspicious behavior.
JENNY BROWN: So there you
have it, another episode
of Cloud Security Basics.
Next episode, we'll be looking
into this so-called security
breach.
So stay tuned for the rest
of the Cloud Security Basics
Series, because when
it comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]